(Spanish guitar music)
(intense hip hop music)
- [Man] I bought my office crush a rose
not knowing she had two weeks off work.
I left it in my locker
and it looked good enough
to give her when she came back.
The head fell off as I handed it to her.
- [Crowd] Awww!
- [Woman] I got food
poisoning from a burrito bowl
at my boyfriend's house.
Then his heat went out and it
was one of the coldest days
of the year.
I had to wear my winter coat in his bed
covered in three blankets while trying not
to (bleep) my pants.
At least he was very nice about it.
- [Man] In high school we used
to give each other carnations
as Valentines.
Every one in our school
got flowers from friends,
very special someone's,
except for me.
Four years and not a single flower.
- [Woman] Last Valentine's day,
my long distance boyfriend
and I got into a fight.
I tried to say sorry by sending
him a heart-shaped pizza
from Pizza Hut.
And 30 minutes later I got a call saying
(buzzing)
he refused the delivery.
When she asked what I
wanted to do with it,
I started crying and told her to eat it.
- [Woman] My long distance
internet boyfriend
of several years surprised
me at my college dorm
on February 13th.
It was the first time we met in person.
But when I invited him to stay the night,
he revealed he was just
stopping through Illinois
on his way to New York
where he was moving to live with his
actual girlfriend.
- [Crowd] Awwww!
- [Man] I had to go for a
colonoscopy on Valentine's day.
Romantic as (bleep).
(hip hop music)